salut récemment j'ai découvert un casse
tête un peu spécial parce que on peut
cacher un cadeau à l'intérieur c'est à
dire que au départ le casse tête n'est
pas fait après on forme le casse tête et
on offre le casse-tête à quelqu'un il
doit le résoudre pour avoir le cadeau
qui à l'intérieur je me suis dit c'est
une super idée à faire sur ma chaîne
mais forcément comme c'est moi qui ai
créé le casse tête qu'il est qu'ils
aient fini de le monter je sais l'ouvrir
donc je me suis ni en cette nouvelle
année pourquoi pas offrir un cadeau à
monsieur loïc génériques
j'avais peur que tu mettes un générique
peut-être damien génériques parce que
dès que je dis le mot générique
en fait c'est chiant loïc je t'ai mis un
cadeau dans ce casse tête tu vas devoir
le résoudre pour avoir ce cadeau de
nouvelle a dit qu heureux oui est ce que
tu veux bien faire ce casse tête à l'est
son nom et bbox bbox voilà wcom bis bis
qui veut dire b nom qui veut dire
abeilles direct à ressemble un petit peu
à une alvéole de ruches
vous allez devenir saad hariri
commentaires évidemment et puis surtout
à la fin de la vidéo si loïc arrive à le
résoudre vous serez le cadeau qui est à
l'intérieur
sinon l'offrir à quelqu'un d'autre
quelqu'un d'autre qui prendra peut-être
ta place ici enfin je peux pas te mettre
la pression frère tu vois c'est cool à
l'étudiante à la casse tête
loïc pour une fois sur un casse tête je
ne sais pas ce qui me prend génériques
[Musique]
géré loïc pour une fois c'est moi qui
s'il a derrière la caméra donc je tu
peux me solliciter je ferai le loïc au
caire je suis ici je te fais le point et
le loïc ok pas bien oui oui obtient un
très fin mais il faut toujours être faut
être au taquet fabien sait ce qu'on doit
faire quand on commence un cas cette
question qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on fait
on fait la phase d'exploration axée les
s'étirer que le dec accélération
ponctuée alors phase d'exploration bien
cadeaux dedans bien cadeaux correct qui
ressemble fort à celui d un cadenas
vraiment ok alors c'est parti et movie
bhl amovible non ça c'est je sais pas à
qui elle est je sais juste qu'elle est
mauvaise
ok donc ça c'est amovible il ya des
petites roues sur le côté et écrit bbox
comme une abeille
comme tout à chacun le sait n'est pas
une boîte d'abeilles donc j'espère c'est
pas des avenues du que ce qu'imaginent
suis allergique mais je suis allergique
fois bien est-ce que tu allergique aux
abeilles je ne sais pas c'est peut-être
l'occasion de savone c'est super
dangereux comme caisse était alors ça ça
bouge je ne sais pas ce qui pourrait
voir à travers là je distingue une une
couleur il ya une couleur une couleur
verte
un peu qu'ils aient un peu verte donc
jeu il ya ça à l'intérieur
donc je sais pas ce que c'est c'est de
la guimauve à l'intérieur peut-être tu
m'as offert des guimauves la ya plein de
petits points je vais appuyer un peu
partout pour voir si ça bouge ça ne
bouge pas
ça bouge pas donc il ya vraiment que ça
qui bouge là pour l'instant
ou derrière ça on se doute que non alors
qu'est-ce qui ça ça bouge de façon ça
bouge quoi ok donc ça rien ça rien sans
rien et on va arriver sur le premier
blocage de loïc g en phase d'exploration
ça est-ce que c'est pas genre ah ah non
en fait c'est juste que je dérive et un
deux trois quatre cinq six dérivés à la
dérive et de cissé quoi et ça va le mec
qui n'est pas à la vidéo il veut
balancer son savoir ce que c'est pas un
truc où on fait ce genre là ça souvent
non
ok moi même accélération fut du cul du
cul mais on dit loïc accélération bah
moi même et bien comme je suis toi
aujourd'hui ouais donc s'il va faire le
montage aussi fabien hockey fabien oui
accélération je viens de remarquer
quelques remarques et j'ai remarqué
quelque chose là je vais te le dire sur
ces petits rivet con qu'on voit ici la
voilà celui ci alors comment je leur nom
sur celui ci a un côté plat quand on
peut le voir ici et je me dis est-ce que
ça c'est pas fait pour tirer avec son
doigt parce que les autres si on n'a pas
donc moi j'ai pas donc de base mais si
on n'a pas d'emblée plaque alors je
tiers ce match a comme vous pouvez le
constater ça s'enlève up
donc j'ai un petit pic ou non qu'est-ce
que je peux faire avec ce pic ou non me
crever un oeil oui mais alors qu'à
partir là dessus ce petit pichonets
qu'est ce que je peux en faire de
l'icône et je peut l'insérer la haye a
des trous il ya un bbox vous pouvez voir
lundi bbox il ya eu un trou est ce que
peut-être on ne se tendent pas de
d'insérer cette tige dans le trou
national de youtube
il est à l'intérieur de cette boîte
d'accord bah alors un instant je me
permets message de l'intérêt sur youtube
j'aimais les cages tech
non mais j'attends qu'ils me répondent
oui mais dans les commentaires peut-être
vous aimez les castels et c'est le cas
sachez que sur cette chaîne
il y en a un par mois vous voulez être
notifiée de l'apparition de ces casses
têtes sur la chaîne eh bien ça tombe
bien grâce à l'abonnement vous pouvez ou
pas être notifiée mais la plupart du
temps oui non l'objet du tantale pologne
la plupart du temps tu as même modèle
que oui parce que je ne sais pas si vous
savez à peine 40% des gens qui regardent
les vidéos sont abonnés s'il vous plaît
tristesse on a dit c'est bien triste
s'il vous plaît vraiment c'est quelque
chose que je veux pour la nouvelle année
c'est qu'on galère dit qu'on galère en
galère abonnez-vous à la chaîne de
fabien olicard dit chatons les gens
aiment bien les châtie non les chatons
vont mourir et on ne veut pas que les
chatons marque
abonnez-vous sur le bouton abonnement
qui ressemble à ceux à ceux ci qui est
sous votre lecteur très peu trop peu
trop mais après vous faites vraiment
comme vous voulez mais ça peut faire
plaisir je vous force vraiment pas mes
pensées au château est penché à la
cloche
ce que vaut si on s'abonne sans la
cloche les chatons merci merci merci à
mon jour
merci bonjour j'ai donc ma tiges que je
vais inséré dans le trou être pas faux
alors là je le mets directement dans le
bbox parce que ça semble assez obvious
qui en anglais veut dire observé pas du
tout on y va je les mises
je vais appuyer ne s'est rien passé mais
j'ai senti une petite résistance
ça rebondit c'est comme s'ils avaient
homme tu sais les choses qui rebondit ce
type un trampoline alors peut-être qu'il
ya un mini trampoline là dedans donc ça
ça ne fait rien je vais essayer dans les
autres ou
[Musique]
bon bah ça ça n'a pas marché est-ce que
je n'ai pas oublié quelque chose dans ma
phase d'exploration
nous le serons assez vite ce que je peux
pas appuyer avec ça sur quelque chose
merde rien à
je viens de voir quelque chose soit bien
avec les stylos en effectuant ce
mouvement rotatif avec mes mains ok
j'observais les autres creux qu'on peut
appeler aussi des glissades
je m'étais la nana na na na na et tout
d'un coup
qu'est ce que je vois juste là un petit
bout de bois qui ressemble à de la
résine je me dit avec mon petit pays
cooney dossier de retirer ce petit bout
de bois avec dextérité à sa se retient
exactement
dorénavant avec ce petit bout de bois en
ma possession je ne veux plus jamais
être tout petit dans des mini dabo loïc
noter ces mini dans survie l'attend
pourcentage pour thème unis dans ubuntu
de gencives jean cheese elle j'en chie
bike mais dans je vais retenter ce que
j'ai fait avec ça tout à l'heure je vais
pénétrer là et je l'appuie y est
peut-être que si j'appuie plus fort se
passe toujours rien peut-être dans
l'autre sens ah j'ai l'impression
d'avoir pénétré dans quelque chose
collection de type c'est vrai que
collection de vidéos et là je ne peux
plus le ressortir comme s'il était armé
non là c'est bloqué d'accord qu'est ce
que ça fait si j'ai fait ça est ce que
quelque chose à chaud est ce que je vois
encore le truc vert que jouer au début
je l'impression que je ne le vois plus
ça n'a rien changé là dessus alors
attentes
ah bah en fait c'est moi qui était
mauvais jeu pouvait clairement retirer
le truc ne jugez pas pu bouger les
chatons vous mourir aussi que ça change
quelque chose
bercy a tant fait loi mais entre temps
la musique au loin à l'horizontale à
music hall ont aussi pas bien
oh arrêtez arrêtez
j'aimerais remercier tous ceux qui m'ont
fait confiance ce qu'ils n'ont pas fait
confiance aussi voudrais vous remercier
de m'avoir fait confiance puisque ça
fait pas plaisir des numéros d'humour es
tu connais la blague à deux balles
la blague à deux balles à la blague à
deux balles maintenant je ne connais pas
de wii pape en voilà alors qu'est ce
qu'on a à l'intérieur fabien olicard
fabien olicard à l'intérieur je dors par
contre c'est un truc que je suis un truc
que je comprends pas c'est que le
mécanisme pourquoi d'avoir appuyé sur un
truc nous alors qu'elle rien de trucs
attends attends attends je vois quelque
chose interdite à ton cadeau quand même
je le vois le voir aussi c'est une sorte
de d'écrou de bagnols ou un truc comme
ça les écroulé c'est vrai on s'en
souvient on va faire une accélération
sur la syrie de casser à voilà je te
présente le casse tête
infiniti difficulté 7 sur 7 ou 6 sur 6
enfin difficulté maximum d'accord ça
casse tête qui prend des heures à
résoudre
oui c'est ça ton cadeau que tu pourras
faire le mois prochain ou le mois
d'après si tu le souhaites d'accord mais
toi tu veux pas le réseau il a l'air
bien galère quand même ouais mais tu
peux peut-être le résoudre toi parce que
je crois que tes lectures de cassettes
tu veux m'offrir mon cadeau je t'offre
ton cas de ces packs c'est parce que ce
qui est important fabien dans la vie
mais moi en tant que que personne
humaine que je pense qui est important
c'est les changes
ok c'est le don les changes genre l'euro
au delà
exactement il faut être au courant de ça
pourquoi je t'offre de castets infiniti
en vrai parce qu'il ya deux casse-tête
dont a énormément parlé sur cette chaîne
qui sont le gabon jour qui sont le
casse-tête excalibur qui est introuvable
aujourd'hui est le casse-tête infiniti
que je t'offre la situant ce le fait à
deux on essaiera de moi je te propose de
le faire tout seul et si tu as besoin
d'elle parce que tu galères je peux
venir t'aider
ou alors j'essaie de le faire tout seul
et quand j'ai compris comment il marche
je te l'offre ensuite ça c'est gentil en
fait tu doit gonfler un petit ballon que
tu fais rentrer ici sous cette qualité
et du coup ce ballon fait se lever ça
donne une espèce de petit pistons qui
rend du coup dans ce creux et qui rend
le déplacement et du coup effectivement
là là où tu as été très rapide c'est le
trou de bbox
il faut y aller quand tu chopes le
chlore donc tueur donc que tu des faits
grâce à ces petits clous du piston et
tel geste à le percer son départ il ya
que trois étapes mais en vrai c'est cool
quoi tu vois pas ce qu'il faut les
trouver c'est pas si simple
et c'est une manière originale d'offrir
un cadeau à quelqu'un ben j'ai beaucoup
aimé j'aime bien même s'il offre un
casse-tête à travers moi aujourd'hui je
le fais pas gagner sur instagram ça je
t'offre la boîte si tu veux faire un
vrai cadeau à quelqu'un et perpétuent la
tradition et surmont instagram
je vous offre du plaisir et du loisir
dans mes story et mes posts et mon
nouveau format qui s'appelle caféine
c'est vrai que vous pouvez regarder mon
insu achète sa fiche il est temps
instagram sors de ton et regarde hop
voilà ça c'est reste à g de loïc et je
te le range dans l'oreille voilà merci
lolo du 22 j'espère que ça t'a plu
j'espère que ça vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à venir vous voir aussi
les dates de spectacles je suis en
tournée en ce moment ici ici ici ici et
ici
dans ces cinq villes mais il ya encore
trente villes derrière donc n'hésitez
pas à venir vivre voilà vous avez le
lien dans la description ainsi que le
lien vers mon tout dernier livre
loïc je crois que j'ai tout dit il me
semble aussi fabien like et la vidéo si
ça vous a plu
merci loïc like et s'il voulait plus de
lui dit que dans les commentaires à très
bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]